das schöne ist Herr Gießerei hat ja eine
Lösung heute mitgebracht was man jetzt
schon mal tun könnte bei der
Energiekrise ja auf jeden Fall
in ganz Europa wird derzeit über die
Energie über das Thema Energie
gesprochen die Haushalte die Unternehmen
machen sich Sorgen wie es im Herbst oder
Winter weiter geht Energiesicherheit
Energieversorgung das ist Thema Nummer
eins und die Länder die starten in der
Europäische Union haben sich gegenseitig
versprochen in dieser schwierigen Zeit
zusammen zu sein sich solidarisch zu
verhalten und sich auch gegenseitig in
einer möglichen Energiekrise zu
unterstützen nur ein Land verhält sich
derzeit aus meiner Sicht nicht
solidarisch das ist Deutschland denn
Deutschland möchte im Grunde genommen
wenn man wenn man hört was der
Wirtschaftsminister sagt von dem
Instrument der Laufzeitverlängerung
nicht gebrauch machen und ich finde in
der jetzigen Situation musste genau das
Gegenteil der Fall sein die drei noch am
Netz verfügbaren Kernkraftwerke müssen
aus meiner Sicht länger laufen bis 2024
das ist ein Instrument um die
Energiekrise in Deutschland zu
verhindern
Herr Bosbach was hat die Union uns da
angetan weil das kann ich jetzt wirklich
nicht der FDP anlasten eigentlich dass
die Atomkraftwerke das würde darüber
heute überhaupt debattieren müssen nein
erst hatten wir den Ausstieg dann kam
die neue Koalition dann haben wir die
Verlängerung dann kam Fukushima dann kam
der Ausstieg insofern ist ihre
Beschreibung jedenfalls am Ende
zutreffend und wir würden wahrscheinlich
heute anders entscheiden was ich jetzt
sage ist jetzt nicht besonders
freundlich aber ich war ja dabei so war
das kein einziger Ministerpräsident
wollte noch an der an der Kernkraft
festhalten keine einzige das gilt
übrigens auch für Volker Bouffier damals
ministerpräsident Horst Seehof in Bayern
die alle in ihren Bundesländern
Kernkraftwerke haben es war nicht Frau
Merkel alleine es war aber auch die
Hoffnung mit der Kehrtwende noch die
Landtagswahl in Baden-Württemberg
gewinnen zu können seitdem ist er
Kretschmann Ministerpräsident
ja wir können jetzt wieder Vertrauen auf
die Seite der Union ziehen
zurückgewinnen in der Sache stimme ich
Herrn joserei völlig zu aber aus einem
etwas anderen Grund wir sollten alles
unterlassen was dazu führt dass Gas
verbrannt wird zur Stromerzeugung und
zwar aus zwei Gründen Gas ist knapp wir
sollten es für Wärme brauchen oder für
die Produktion und Gas ist teuer solange
wirrit order-prinzip haben bestimmt die
teuerste Form der Energieversorgung den
Preis für alle anderen auch für die
preiswerten
energieerzeugungsformen Sonne und Wind
da gibt es ja auch zufallsgewinne die
jetzt abgeschöpft werden soll also dass
der eine Grund der anderen Grund weil
Gas immer teurer wird gibt es immer
höhere Zusatzgewinne bei den anderen
ohne dass deren Produktionskosten
gestiegen sind das haben wir aber eine
Frage angenommen nur aus pädagogischen
Gründen unterstellt die Union bringt
einen Antrag ein zur Verlängerung
Laufzeit bis Ende 24 dann noch am Netz
befindlichen Kernkraftwerke
würden Sie dem zustimmen also zunächst
einmal die Union hatte ja vor einigen
Wochen diesen Antrag gestellt und ich
habe mich obwohl ich der Koalition oder
einer koalitionsfraktion angehöre hat
mich dort enthalten allerdings wissen
sie auch sie wissen ganz genau wie das
funktioniert wenn ein Antrag der
Opposition kommt aber ein Antrag der
Ampel ich bin ja echtes Beispiel aber
in der Endphase ja genau allerdings muss
man sagen das ist das ist trotzdem das
ist ein Thema da kommen wir nicht
drumherum sondern
ein Nebenschauplatz da sollten wir jetzt
nicht hingehen wichtig ist dass diese
Koalition bei dem Thema tatsächlich von
dem Instrument der Laufzeitverlängerung
Gebrauchtwagen wir verhalten uns in ganz
Europa derzeit unsolidarisch ich möchte
das aber fragen warum stimmt man dann
jetzt gar nicht um sie hinziehen aber
warum enthält man sich dann wenn man
aber eigentlich dem Antrag der
Opposition zustimmt vom Herzen her das
ist eine Frage der der koalitionstechnik
und Disziplin bei mir ist das in der
Regel sehr sehr oft so dass ich
inhaltlich sehr nah bin an den
Positionen der der Union
Bundestagsfraktion aber nicht desto
trotz wenn man einmal damit anfängt es
ist jetzt unabhängig von welchem Thema
dann hat auch eine Koalition keinen Sinn
mehr dann ist auf bricht auch eine
Regierung schnell zusammen das heißt
dann werden Sie auch bei anderen Themen
nicht mehr handlungsfähig sein deswegen
ist es an der Stelle nicht eine Frage
der Technik sondern das ist hier eine
inhaltliche Debatte die muss diese
Koalition führen und ich erwarte vom
deutschen Wirtschaftsminister dass er an
der Stelle die Interessen des Landes im
Blick hat
es denn Herr Saray dass er Habeck noch
die Kehrtwende macht
Herr Habeck wird aus meiner Sicht nicht
Politik machen gegen Physik
wir
natürlich spielen wahltaktische Gründe
hier eine Rolle weil auch eine
Landtagswahl in Niedersachsen gibt und
man habe auch dort hofft vor allem weil
die Grünen in Niedersachsen ja auch sehr
aktiv das Thema also gegen
Kernkraftwerke sich auch als Thema
positionieren kann genau und von daher
spielt das an der Stelle eine Rolle aber
wie kommt er nicht drumherum wir sind
unten den Menschen in Deutschland
verpflichtet bei dem Thema voranzukommen
und wir sind auch unseren europäischen
Partnern verpflichtet an der Stelle
Solidarität zu zeigen und ich glaube das
ist auch eine realistische Debatte
niemand sagt hier wie sollen im Bereich
der Kerntechnik jetzt dauerhaft
einsteigen das sagte niemand sondern es
ist nur eine Laufzeitverlängerung bis
sie haben genickt als er jäserei geredet
ich habe genickt weil er sehr präzise
die machttechniken innerhalb einer mehr
parteienkoalition geschrieben hat sehr
ehrlich also sie sind in meiner Achtung
noch etwas mehr gestiegen also muss
jetzt ehrlich sagen dass Sie das sagen
sehr ehrlich ach wirklich ja ich
Dauerwerbesendungen einblenden
gleichwohl ist natürlich die Frage was
erreicht man damit wenn wir dieser
Forderung offenbar am Kabinettstisch
nicht durchtrinken und stattdessen Radio
Interviews gibt in die Öffentlichkeit
geht in Talkshows geht und sagt habe
kommt zu Potte gleichzeitig hören wir
die Aussagen von Prominenten Figuren an
der Spitze der Grünen die immer noch
sagen seine Phantom Debatte die
Geschichte habe ihr endgültiges Urteil
über die Atomenergie gefällt noch dazu
das ist natürlich auch genauso ehrlich
das also ich mag das Wort ja nicht an
dem Fall stimmt das also alte weiße
Männer ihr Erbe gefährdet sehen und
deshalb lieber die Deindustrialisierung
in Kauf nehmen als eine schlechte Legacy
sozusagen und das aber glaube ich die
wirklich entscheidende Frage ist dass du
ein Ausdruck von Stärke der FDP dass sie
in der Öffentlichkeit seine
kontraposition gehen oder Schwäche weil
man im Kabinett sonst überhaupt nichts
mehr erreichen würde Frau würdig sind
sie denn als Bürgerin wenn Sie das Hören
auch mit der taktierung in der Politik
was denken sie denn ich fand das schon
spannend ich glaube auch dass das wenn
ich das jetzt so richtig
gefiltert habe hier das ist schon an der
Zeit wird und da kriegt dem kann ich
auch nur zustimmen dass jetzt
ministerpolitik gemacht wird und nicht
Parteipolitik
also ich glaube es gibt doch Umfragen
die Wähler und Wähler der Grünen sehen
das etwas anders ich glaube die können
sich mehrheitlich darum geht es ja eine
befristete Verlängerung Angesicht der
katastrophalen Situation auf dem
Energiemarkt vorstellt aber die grüne
Basis sieht das wohl etwas
Niedersachsen auch anders die kommen ja
aus der Friedensbewegung aber seit
neuestem wissen wir das stolze
Kriegsdienstverweigerer schweren Waffen
für die Ukraine rufen das hörte sie auch
früher ganz anders an und jetzt nur noch
das zweite mega Projekt anders laufen
als ursprünglich geplant ist natürlich
für die grüne Seele schwierig
nein wir haben Ölheizung aber leute es
geht um 82 Millionen Menschen es geht um
den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland es
geht um Familienhaushalte die mit dem
Rücken zur Wand stehen und wenn das die
da sind wir uns ja eigentlich in der
Beschreibung der Situation da muss ich
mal sagen ist mir die Gemütslage der
Grünen Basis relativ egal und habe
riskiert wirklich vom Acker ja zu werden
weil er geht nun persönlich mit dieser
Energiepolitik nach Hause und wenn es
wirklich ansatzweise an Blackout käme
wäre das wirklich an seinen
Verantwortung dann werden die Grünen für
Jagd von religionsverantwortung doch die
Grünen also Süddeutsche Zeitung
Langstrecke ist Kistler gerade vorher
richtig Künstler drauf Ruhe habe ich
vorne drauf der Mann der den
Unternehmern die Krise erklärt steht
dann würde ich sagen da fehlt dann auch
die Einblendung dauerwerbes Jahr also
das ist ja wirklich nur teilweise nur
noch Kabarett also ich glaube man muss
sich wirklich den Fakten annähern und
wir haben eine eine energiemangelage und
wenn Herr hab selber sagt es kann schon
nutzen wenn du dich weniger duscht aber
es nutzt nichts wenn ein Atomkraftwerk
mehr läuft dann ist es ein so derartig
großer gucken tiefer Widerstand da kommt
ja keine Süddeutsche drüber hinweg also
bis vor kurzem hieß es übrigens auch wir
haben gar keinen Strom Problem in
Deutschland das darf man auch nicht
vergessen das ist auch von einigen
Seiten aber ich will es noch mal ganz
klar an dieser Stelle sagen ich bin
bereit oder auch sage ich auch als
Generalsekretär der FDP ich bin bereit
diesen Streit innerhalb der Koalition
auszutragen ich weiß nicht wie wie das
ausgeht wird
auch diese Frage ist berechtigt nur ich
weiß ganz genau sie wissen das auch dass
diese Koalition natürlich
außerordentlich schwierig ist für die
FDP und Streit innerhalb der Koalition
ist ein gutes Bild ab wir am Ende
angekommen wir nehmen sie aber